das verschreckt selbst den fachleuten
die sprache denn die galaxie die jetzt
entdeckt wurde enthält keine oder nur
sehr wenig dunkler materie und das ist
wirklich äußerst mysteriös denn bislang
gehen fachleute davon aus dass sich
galaxien aus dunkler materie entwickeln
die aktuelle entdeckung bestätigt somit
nicht nur eine ähnliche messung aus dem
vergangenen jahr sondern stellt auch
viele bisherige annahmen der astronomie
auf den kopf brauchen wir jetzt eine
neue theorie der dunkle materie klicks
und science fiction die gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen
es ist jetzt das zweite mal dass ein
astronomie team eine galaxie aufspürt
die keine oder nur sehr wenig dunkle
materie enthält schon 2018 gab es eine
riesige aufregung um die damals
untersuchte galaxie ngc 1052 df 2 denn
schnell stand fest dass etwas nicht mit
ihr stimmte das forschungsteam entdeckte
nämlich dass die galaxie nicht nur fast
durchsichtig sondern vor allem auch fast
ohne dunkle materie existiert ein
komplettes rätsel alles an ihr ist
merkwürdig hieß es von den beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern
denn nach den bisherigen annahmen
dürften galaxien eigentlich gar nicht
ohne dunkle materie entstehen
und so wurde die studie aus 2008 10 bis
jetzt mit großer skepsis beäugt auch
wenn die dunkle materie selbst für uns
immer noch ein großes rätsel ist glauben
wir zu wissen dass sie der wohl
häufigste stoff im universum ist woraus
dunkle materie genau besteht ist aber
bis heute absolut unklar und
forschungsteams weltweit suchen mit
hochdruck nach einer möglichen erklärung
doch das ist einfacher gesagt als getan
denn die mysteriöse dunkle materie
sendet wieder licht aus noch verschluckt
sie welches ihr nachweis gestaltet sich
aufgrund dessen als äußerst kompliziert
und so musste sich auch das
forschungsteam aus den usa eines tricks
bedienen um die aktuelle entdeckung
überhaupt erst möglich zu machen
dafür nutzen sie die tatsache dass
sternhaufen in galaxien umso schneller
unterwegs sind je mehr dunkle materie
die wir jeweilige galaxie besitzt denn
mit ihrer schwerkraft verändert dunkle
materie eben beispielsweise die
bewegungen der sternhaufen in galaxien
und so nutzen die amerikanischen
wissenschaftler
wissenschaftler das keck teleskop auf
hawaii um insgesamt sieben
kugelsternhaufen in der galaxie ds4 zu
beobachten genauso wie die im jahr 2018
beobachten die galaxie befindet sie sich
etwa 63 millionen lichtjahre von der
erde entfernt auch wenn beide galaxien
von der größe her mit der milchstraße zu
vergleichen sind kann man sie nur schwer
sehen der grund dafür ist dass beide
objekte etwa 100 bis 1000 mal weniger
sterne als die milchstraße enthalten und
das ergebnis belegt dass die messung aus
dem letzten jahr wohl korrekt war
denn auch in dieser zweiten galaxie
bewegen sich die sternhaufen viel
langsamer als sie es eigentlich tun
müssten wenn dunkle materie vorhanden
wäre
die schlussfolgerungen des
forschungsteams ist eindeutig die
beobachtete galaxie kann entweder nur
sehr wenig oder gar keine dunkle materie
enthalten und diese entdeckung macht die
beteiligten experten und expertinnen zum
zweiten mal sprachlos dazu der astronom
pieter van dokkum von der yale
university eine zweite galaxie mit
keiner oder nur sehr wenig sympathie zu
finden war genauso aufregend wie beim
ersten mal
solange es nur ein objektiv hat man
immer diese leise stimme im hinterkopf
die sagt was wenn du dich ist laut der
aktuellen studie legt dieses ergebnis
jetzt aber nah das ist wohl mehr
galaxien ohne dunkle materie gibt als
bislang angenommen
doch wie diese entstanden sind das
bleibt weiter unklar
muss etwa eine alternative theorie über
dunkle materie herangezogen werden um
dieses rätsel endlich lösen zu können
die beteiligten fachleute sind
diesbezüglich skeptisch der
wissenschaftler pieter van dokkum kann
sich vorstellen dass die dunkle materie
in galaxien mit der zeit verloren
gegangen ist eine weitere erklärung
könnte sein dass sie aus gas entstanden
sind dass eine nachbar galaxie
ausgestoßen hat bei all diesen großen
fragezeichen liefert die aktuelle
entdeckung dennoch eine wichtige
erkenntnis nämlich das normale materie
und dunkle materie unabhängig
voneinander entstanden sind dunkle
materie bleibt rätselhaft hier auf das
video draufklicken anschauen und
abonniert habt ihr kriegs um hoffentlich
schon ansonsten bis dann bleib dran